Across the universe, an endless war rages a
bitter struggle between invisible forces.
Dark matter and dark energy battling for
control of the universe.
We've seen this cosmic battle go on for the
past 14 billion years.
Like two navies fighting it out in the ocean
of space time.
Shadowy forces dictating our past, our
present, and our future.
The dark universe is kind of a puppet master
behind the scenes guiding the universe that
we can see.
It's taken over the universe and eventually
it may well destroy the universe.
As we look out across the universe.
We see nebulas stars.
And planets all constructed from visible
matter.
But what we see is just a small part of the
cosmos.
The rest is invisible.
Unknown. The dark universe.
Dark universe is a very common phrase to
describe our universe, because it turns out
most of our cosmos is dark.
Dark? Not as in night.
Dark as in doesn't interact with light.
And dark as in we don't really understand
it.
The dark universe is made of two forces.
Dark matter and dark energy.
In a way, the dark matter and dark energy
sort of oppose each other.
Dark matter has positive gravity that pulls
things together and dark energy has repulsive
gravity that pushes things apart.
Dark matter and dark energy are locked in
this epic struggle.
The dark matter is trying to bring things
together.
The dark energy is trying to drive
everything apart.
All the objects in our daily experience, our
bodies, the air, the chair that you're
sitting in. The planets and stars, all of
that only adds up to 5% of the universe.
It's the other 95% that is the dark stuff.
The dark universe.
To encapsulate that in one sentence.
Dark matter is attractive.
Dark energy is repulsive.
Since the dawn of time, two forces slugging
it out for control of the universe.
It's a struggle that started 13.8 billion
years ago in the cosmic furnace of the Big
Bang. The infant universe was a super hot
ball of intense radiation.
But suddenly.
It started to transform.
It cooled and expanded, triggering the birth
of the regular universe and the dark
universe. Scientists believe that both dark
matter and dark energy formed in the first
moments of the Big Bang.
That would have formed probably just
fractions of a second after the Big Bang.
Around the time that normal matter formed
and the processes that created the normal
matter we know all about similar processes
probably created the dark matter.
During these first microseconds, the universe
was a hot, dense ball of matter and energy.
There are two sides of the same coin.
Matter can convert into energy.
And energy can convert directly into matter.
Visible particles of regular matter forming
atoms, planets, stars and us.
And other particles.
They are invisible.
They are dark matter.
One of the big mysteries that we as
astronomers have to solve is what this dark
matter is. We just don't know.
The idea of a type of matter that you can't
see and that acts differently than normal
matter is sort of out there.
It's sort of weird.
It's like a crime scene, you know, that a
crime has been committed even though you
don't know the perpetrator yet.
We see the hints.
We see the signs.
We see the signals that something funny is
happening in our universe, even though we
don't know exactly what's causing it.
There are several contenders for what dark
matter could be.
It could be normal matter that we just don't
see.
Or it could be some sort of exotic matter, a
particle of some sort that we haven't
detected yet.
It could be a species of particle, like an
electron, like a proton, like a quark, but a
special kind that doesn't interact with
light.
Dark energy has existed since the time of the
Big Bang.
Dark energy was always there.
We don't know how much of it there was, but
it's possible that the same amount of dark
energy was always there.
Dark energy is nothing more than a
placeholder name for this enormous gap in our
understanding of how the cosmos works.
But we don't understand it at all.
What's true.
One potential answer to what dark energy
actually is may be found in so called empty
space. Could this be the source of dark
energy?
We used to think of space as just boring
emptiness, but now I think it's healthier to
think of space as a kind of substance.
A substance that carries a strange type of
energy.
Every small region of space has a little bit
of energy in it just associated with the
vacuum itself.
Vacuum energy is the idea that vacuum isn't
empty, that there is something there.
There's an energy in it with a kind of
anti-gravity.
Perhaps this vacuum energy that pushes
against gravity.
Is the mysterious dark energy we simply
don't know.
We're not sure that the dark energy is the
vacuum energy.
It could be a new type of energy that
permeates all of space.
This is what we're trying to measure now.
Dark energy and dark matter forged in the
intense heat of the Big Bang.
Opposing forces, one attractive, one
repulsive.
But together over 13.8 billion years, they
will shape the history.
Of the universe.
As the cosmic Web evolves into a more complex
structure.
Gaps form between the filaments.
The cosmic voids.
The cosmic voids formed because other more
dense regions of the universe gravitationally
stole material away from them, so the dense
parts of the universe accumulated more matter
at the expense of the less dense parts which
then became voids.
Dark energy played no role.
It was insignificant.
But at some stage in the 14 billion years
since the Big Bang, these roles became
reversed. Dark energy came to be the more
powerful force.
The question was when.
The answer came at the end of the 20th
century.
The beginning of the universe shaping it and
actually creating the conditions for us to be
here. And it's taking over the universe, and
eventually it may well destroy the universe.
Our universe may be dominated by the long
struggle between dark matter and dark energy.
But all of this conflict has led to a
creative outcome, an outcome for which we
should all be grateful.